tell me the bugs love water they still
operate on YouTube lot of Records in for
a premium service ball pops you should
ask why they need the credit card
service if you to abduct it's worth in
the first place
lease Yuki talk who are you no matter
whom OGG Vorbis what nutters is our plan
no.1 kuruma Cromwell's until i put on
the mocha you took his band's your
channel we you in my club just die cool
you seem like a big trainee
[Music]
steady flag part of your plan of course
do they monetize that channel inside of
the younger
well congratulations you got caught the
next step of your master plan to
practices on YouTube my club was created
for the people to join and the support
of Santa Clara generated content they
will sign up another was cousin what's
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and that is the sound of the weekend as
the music fades out today is wrong for
day thank you so much for being with us
so that's your pictures your rompers
producing with me in video studio as
always as Jared who is not gay follow
him on Twitter at knock' Jared me at s
crowded questions
I'm not even could be coming I fulfill
my obligations drunk I can't even speak
clearly it's the skin of my brain draw
your own conclusions are we good right
no go on at G Morgan Jr he picked this
hey by the way before we get to anything
else next week is going to be the free
7-day trial for those on YouTube
watching us on YouTube right now people
who are not mug Club members we do the
daily show live no one's saying well I
want to try it but I can't be bothered
to go off-site because there is a 7-day
free trial over there if you go to a lot
of credit um such mug clubbers here to
be but we are going to do seven full
well sorry seven next week Monday
through Friday all the episodes will be
free care because we care about the
cheapskates yes exactly and because
YouTube is trying to squeeze us out so
you don't know what you're missing great
guys today stefan molyneux yeah manu but
i'll say it the right wrong way and we
have Matt Iseman so what are the most
requested yes yes excited and we'll be
talking about the Trump Comey situation
Russia we did a timeline on Monday but
some things have changed so we didn't
want to touch on it every single day or
we didn't we would have no shows no and
what we'll get into in a minute so in
other news 40,000 the illegal immigrants
have been arrested by ice u.s.
immigrations and Customs Enforcement
they've arrested more than 41,000
dividuals and that's 37.6% more they
compared to a comparable segment of 2016
that's also in doubt such a silver
lining yes this is the sliver of Hope a
special investigator was tasked with
rooting out and finding the illegal
aliens or as it's more commonly known
googling Home Depot
that's Bing will do in a pinch I swear
to you true story Cyclops one-eyed goat
this goat was born in India and well
let's roll the clip so you know it's
real today's ago on this
in India there was a very rare birth of
the condition which causes this cyclone
Indian villagers yeah started
worshipping the goat because they see it
as a baby that sounds familiar but I've
heard that I've heard that sound before
I just that's what it was see it's
either it's either Krishna incarnated or
it's David Bao dr. David Bell they think
he is a deity incarnate when asked for
comment regarding being a dating kind of
the one I'd go to fit himself and ran
into a fence post repeatedly so don't
but these two villagers are holding out
hope that this is a sign of the ultimate
fulfillment of prophecy yet to come the
goat with two [ __ ] fingers crossed
and I give the sign unto you he shall be
called wrigley double the pleasure so a
company came up it English company this
English or Japanese sounds Japanese tell
Japanese they have created and will
begin to sell the world's first talking
sex dog jeez because that's why people
buy weird sex dolls the inventor has
also claimed that this sex doll will
have 18 personalities eighteen
personalities have to fulfill the
long-standing fantasy of screwing james
mcavoy from split apparently people
really want eighteen personalities also
known as every girl after tequila I
don't take sure points it's like ten
grand I know well 1818 personalities for
a small phenomenal upgrade fee you can
actually get the doll to stalk you and
boil your kids pet rabbits oh that's
weird the upgrade yes by the way there's
a software update immediately released
on getting it to shut the hell up that
was the first its iOS there's a new this
is also in its new Star Trek series
using the new star everyone's I just if
sergeant we're playing on a Jumbotron
way back here I wouldn't love to
this is a new series it's going to be
released it's the sixth incarnation of
Star Trek it's already being titled Star
Trek discovery that's what they've
rested on not on the list of anticipated
discovery sex with not your hand to be
followed by Star Trek 7 leaving mom's
basement
Star Trek 8 talking sex doll you saved
up you save milk it's okay
Trump this is situation this week so we
did a timeline earlier this is what
everyone wants and by the way we have a
bet going the Vegas betting odds have
put Donald Trump's chances of being
impeached in his first term at 60% so
what do you think do you think this
isn't fake news this is the Vegas
betting odds well like who said
yesterday money has a way of making
people bringing out corruption and
honestly it could also be brutally
honest yes I mean the guy's not gonna
fall on us the guy's not going to just
well I hate Donald Trump so I'm going to
he's gonna create a bet where he can't
possibly win I thought that's the first
time there has been a greater chance of
him being impeached those betting odds
right now what do you think will place
our own bet
so we'll bet what do you bet do you
think Donald Trump was impeached first
term so he's given the odds on it like
yeah 60% odds that he will no no no I'll
take that money every day okay yeah I
don't think he'll be impeached either I
bet no ever the sound guy bets no not
get Jared I think I don't think we'll be
in peace I would bet he'll resign
courts over who's you you bet he'll
resign I would bet heroes resign no and
if you lose a bad two marriages already
look dude that he was okay whoever loses
with that has to walk down a crowded
Street and there mani panties but I
don't know when we do nude scenes at
ladder with Crowder we wear my panties
so it looks like we're out it's true
with defined crowded as crowded as we
can find out geez all right so let's
give you the time line for those who
missed it some people and say can you
just compile this because it's hard to
make sense of it I understand
may 9th Donald Trump fires call me okay
so that was people were saying well this
is clearly trying to obstruct justice
with the FBI investigation Russia okay
that's not necessarily the case then
Trump's meat that Trump meets with the
Russians okay
and he was accused of leaking classified
information his team goes out and said
well he didn't leak classified
information II didn't even address
sensitive information Donald Trump
tweets out that he did
sensitive information not classified
information that's important because one
is a legal term by the way he's a
president he can declassify whatever he
wants and one is just you probably
shouldn't discuss issues that relate to
national security with the Russians then
of course what happened is Trump asked
comer you can get rid of the prompter by
the way from Basco me for the Flint
investigation - and that's alleged
that's a memo and they worry about that
in the New York Times and then of course
now there's a special counsel for the
Russia investigation a couple of things
here III do think that this is showing
us some some leadership flaws with
Donald Trump has he broken the law it
does not seem that way but he is not
being cohesive with his message he's
sending them out with talking points and
then he's contradicting them I feel bad
for Sean Spicer I feel bad for Kellyanne
Conway I used to think Sean Spicer was
an idiot I just don't I think he has an
impossible job yeah so the problem is he
can make leftists right just by making
these constant mistakes on the flip side
you know there was a fight on CNN about
this when every single source is unnamed
when every single source is anonymous I
get you have to protect your sources I
understand that but at a certain point
if this is going to get legal a source
is going to be revealed so it's what the
left does is they just anonymous we
heard this do you deny the allegations
that really bothers me what also bothers
me is Donald Trump not just having a
team huddle before it goes on Twitter
and completely contradicts his national
security advisers what do you think how
bad has this been for Donald Trump I
think this has been terrible but it's
all it's kind of foreseeable - he does
some stuff he has some missteps but then
they have these sources by the way were
two former people associated with this
they're not people that are currently
writing a deal so I'm just like come on
how reliable is this and then for her to
get up and yell like that at this guy
saying well who the sources it's a
reasonable question yeah so I don't
think anything's gonna come of it though
well I mean like you what were you
saying you were saying he's kind of
running the government as always running
his as he ran his business so there's
nothing wrong with I think it's better
to run the government like a business
than a non-profit as a community
organizer from Chicago did we were
talking with us yesterday
he's never he's handling this exactly
how you'd expect Donald Trump in his
businesses right to handle running an
office and it's it's everything's favors
were favors he doesn't really
we'll just it's fine when you're
skirting the law in your own business
and being kind of you know
yeah that is true dishonest but its hold
everything when you know allegations of
obstruction of justice are coming
forward and that's that's a hold
everything they're running a business
and you can't just scratch your back
mind for yours to get you out of here
two things try to have justice I don't
think he's been obstructing justice what
I do think is this has shown that before
the end of his term he can slip he is a
liability he's a liability because he
doesn't think before he speaks and he's
been allowed to get away with that for
his whole life because think about it
from the moment he was able to
understand money as a concept every
relationship he's had has been someone
subservient to him you know he can buy
or sell people fee they're gonna do what
I like cuz I pay their salary he's
sitting with his with his administration
you're seeing him fire people if they
criticize him that you're seeing him
fire people just because he doesn't like
them he's using them politically now I
don't think he's used to having adult
relationships with people who are as his
equal because he's always had a leg up
now there's nothing wrong with being
born into wealth but I do think you know
listen what really worries me is they're
going to say it's his lack of experience
I don't I think someone can go into
office as a business person with lack of
experience but a business person who
came from the middle class or lower
middle class who built up a product or
service and created a business and
employed people it's very different from
someone who was leveraging loans eminent
domain filing you know chapter 11
bankruptcy it's a different business
model know people criticize Mitt Romney
because there's anyways Bain Capital
that's differently all he does is go in
and gut gut these businesses and make
them more profitable that's kind of what
we needed with government someone who
had that kind of business experience and
the kind of business experience Donald
Trump has you can see him trying to run
government that way and I just I hope he
takes some advice from people who could
help and I think there's a problem with
right now if people say always he's he's
not joining the swamp in it like with
Comey he just fired him in much away the
same kind of fashion he would have fired
a an employee that was not it must a way
to see what kind of fashion and what
happened okay go ahead in much the same
way you would have fired an employee who
refused to toe the line it was yeah it
didn't do it in a way that this is an
independent FBI a repeat of the United
States man he's now becoming a little
bit of a douchey president we support he
did it in a way that wasn't even
consistent with what he told his team
tell the press I agree they were like
well no this letter was written he's
like gosh good ol arrows gonna fire them
anyway
and it's just like you know again a
leader should make the people who follow
him look better yes he should make him
look smarter than they are
he should want to elevate the people who
work for him more than himself that's
what a good leader does and so this
isn't he's not obstructing justice
I want to see the guy do well but I
think for the guy to do well he needs to
stop giving these gifts to the left and
I would like to see him elevate his team
as opposed to shifting them around when
they do something do you think he knew
he was under investigation by the FBI
yeah I think do you think he knows the
difference oh yeah I do I think he knows
a difference I know I don't think Donald
Trump's unintelligent I don't like he's
super intelligent I think he's of
average intelligence and I think he's
out of touch because of the life that
he's lived and and I think the other
seeing yeah and you're seeing some of
those consequences and I think the media
is is this is a big witch hunt it's
completely a liability it's so it's just
not a good situation it's it's it's
complicated because you come from
Morocco bottle where the media swept
everything under the rug yeah exactly
and think the contrast makes it so much
worse and yes and so it makes people who
otherwise would be thinking critically
of some of Donald Trump's mistakes to
completely gloss over them because the
media has put him on his heels so much
yeah when they were so soft on Obama so
I understand those dynamics and it's
just been an exhausting week speaking of
which ok Planned Parenthood has a new
video out at the tiller of this
advertise you know it's one of those
things where you wouldn't realize until
you hold on a second I'm watching this
this is evil you're watching a PSA for
Planned Parenthood and then you realize
what they're promoting is evil
josh joss whedon avengers Fame I guess
going back to Buffy the Vampire Slayer
directed wrote I don't know created this
Planned Parenthood spot that people are
praising let's let's let's go through it
and see just why so here we lead off
dramatic music sounds just like a move
well produced sounds just like a motion
picture that's a reverse to tears
it's a reversed here it screwed me up so
you're seeing right now everything is
occurring in Reverse this is the theme
of the advertisement for Planned
Parenthood
[Music]
very bad so we're talking about breast
cancer we'll come back to that in a
minute right away no shame in painting
black Americans at a negative light no
apparently Joss Whedon's and Parenthood
planned parent they've been doing to the
beginning of time Margit Sagar thought
that they were stupid he thought that
they were less I guess less evolved
human beings if you look at some of the
writing she believed in eugenics and
that's one thing - my wife works at a
price crisis pregnancy center everyone
who comes in in 2017 knows about birth
control
so don't let lists before they get to
the whole birth control thing no one
buys that okay a lot of people who come
in just didn't want to use it that's
that's she's like 1913 that's what it is
I she has yet to see someone who didn't
know that you could get condoms for 25
cents at a truck stop so that's
important to note here with Planned
Parenthood because this is their
constant argument ever when I was a kid
they said well black Americans don't
have access to computers in their
library so they don't know about birth
control and now that you said well black
black Americans don't know how
uneducated how ignorant must do you
think black Americans are to say that in
2017 they don't know about birth control
this is racism yes by low expectations
all right let's keep going with this
advertisement as though it's going
really well
[Music]
more reverse
Oh Scholarship can't let a human life
getting away that you have women's
studies to get to I'll hold your regret
hold your regret so again this is a
clear-cut example that abortion is
sacrifice at the altar itself we've
talked about it this commercial is
making it compassionate and beautiful my
scholarship as she holds a living being
but if we go in Reverse you can kill it
you can't kill let's continue with this
advertisement see the problems would be
solved if they walked through the doors
at Planned Parenthood look sex education
for those who don't have Bing really I
didn't even know I was having sex I
never even heard about birth control
Thank You Planned Parenthood oh look I
love this by the way look at this they
gloss over that they show the black
woman yeah with a rag over her they go
back to her yeah I think they come back
to it
do they come on a second she's going to
school we're so proud of our little
little murderer they don't go back to it
either all right that's enough so I love
how they're they show they show the
black woman by the way with this towel
over and this is the one with breast
cancer so they're checking her yeah by
the way we have more employees and
Planned Parenthood has mammogram
machines sure they don't provide they
cannot provide breasts get adequate
breast cancer screenings yeah when you
say planter doesn't pray mammograms go
oh just right wing nope nope they never
have they cannot provide mammograms
period no one told that black woman that
just the dishonesty as a plan here's a
deal - my wife works at a crisis
pregnancy center okay people come in
there's not Planned Parenthood and yep I
will tell you full disclosure it is more
of a faith-based crisis pregnancy
centers they do provide birth control
they provide sex education but their
incentive is to try and get the person
to either have the baby given they
provide adoption services they provide
support for single mothers all of that
they do all of it and they very often
find that women go in there with the
idea of abortion and can be very easily
convinced to not do so as a matter of
fact they're often pressured by a
boyfriend the most
in Scenario is a new about birth control
didn't use it and a boyfriend doesn't
want to have the baby so the woman goes
along with it and very often they are
encouraged to either keep the baby give
it up for adoption and more of these
women leave go to school they're
actually inspired Planned Parenthood's
money maker almost exclusively but their
biggest moneymaker for sure is abortion
so they are just as incentivized as my
wife is where she works to get them to
provide this baby for adoption by the
way there are foster parents like their
parents right now lined up who are
trying to get kids and who can't plant
burnt is just as incentive just as
incentivized to get them to kill their
baby so whether you walk into a Planned
Parenthood or some other crisis
pregnancy center which provide better
health care better resources and better
references that almost will determine
statistically whether you abort your
baby or not how is that not evil it's
absolutely evil and they they don't do
anything good they just basically scar
women for life the girl that walked into
the college scene for that she had the
abortion oh good that works out in the
next few years and then I got a PhD and
social studies
but usually they go with a cinematic
it's a cinematic feel so it's okay they
were dead-set you know if you look at
the the articles they were dead-set they
wanted to make it look like a film they
were they were really married to the
idea of a film producer from from film
not television well in the heart stream
yeah it's all in the heart runs which is
interesting because actually you know
they went with Joss Whedon but they had
another direction with taking a
filmmaker yeah the well the first
filmmaker screen test was almost as
tasteful no consequence just throw you
in the waste no responsibility I only
think of me and just because I can
Allah thoughts my baby byebye baby in my
sea so and air bye-bye
it's just I don't care here's just I
don't
okay
it is just I don't care what a leaden
stefan molyneux coming up next then Matt
Iseman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright glad to have our next guest this
nothing is done well today with this are
actually polka Pogo is a fan of I think
when he's in the show he talked about
him one of the most requested guests
here's here's the bacteria I thought for
sure he would never come on the show I
didn't because I thought when we first
started the show remember we would send
out requests and everyone said no yeah
long time ago and then then we saw that
he's he's a secret member of the of the
Mudd Club and I followed him for a while
Pogo likes and people of request and
there we go
Irish by way of Canada Stefon Molineux
you can follow all stefan molyneux you
can follow us off at free domain
radio.com did I get that right Stefan
that's you know as far as an American
goes that is a fairly good track at the
French syllables and I you know given
the very intimidating t-shirt you have
on I'm just gonna say that was perfect
my friend good job thank you but well I
guess it's it's stefan molyneux I can
say but I was in Montreal but I tried do
you find this in the United States you
try and say it the right wrong way
wouldn't saying something in French like
lingerie is it's not a French word so
I'm like Angley lingerie the first time
I read it and they're like what are you
talking you mean lingerie it's like oh
that's how you say it okay well so the
other day I did a show where I was
mentioning yeah what's the French phrase
for deja vu again or something like that
of course a whole bunch of helpful
commodore said you know that is French I
just wanted to help Steve Martin he has
a certain I don't know what so there was
a guy actually bought Charlie David
Pryor he talked about people using
French words they were erotic he was
like you know people say you know I like
sleeping Oh naturelle do you think that
anyone in Paris right now is saying we
moi him dummy buck naked doesn't have
the same same effect but why a French
name if you're Irish well this goes way
back so my family originally came over
with William the Conqueror in 1066 in
the Battle of Hastings my understanding
is that we were fairly alpha to a bunch
of ha starving Irish peasants ended up
being awarded some land and then I had I
think it was a great-grandfather who
strangely enough for an Irishman enjoyed
the bottle quite a bit
and trading off land for liquor and and
thus we would cost forward into the
world to make our way
among the normies and so far I actually
think it was a very very good change on
the family tree
yeah well he's what we would call an
outlier for an Irishman so okay so I'm
really glad to have in the show
obviously you're a big presence on
YouTube everyone's been talking about
this we'll get into kind of some Trump
issues later topical stuff but YouTube
the D monetization scandal I guess it's
going on you've been on top of this but
what's your take on it because we've
tried to express the new ones with our
audience YouTube is free to do whatever
they want but they are changing the game
on content creators who helped build the
site and and that's my issue with them I
have two minds about it Steve so I'll
tell you what I think of them you guys
let me know what you think of course
right so the first thing is I have
sympathy for the people who've got
payroll to meet you've got bills to pay
and so on and who are relying on this
and I've seen people you know big famous
YouTube guys they're posting like 90%
reduction ninety five percent I even saw
one 98 percent reduction and I'm pretty
sure his light went out during the
actual show cuz he I couldn't even pay
the electricity bill so like the grinch
simple death and some wire yeah yeah
we'll be doing the show outside from now
on because nature's lighting is so I
think that it's really really tough for
the people who've got that kind of stuff
on the other hand I really like that the
left if they are the ones behind and I
think it's fairly safe to say that they
are I love that the left is not making
an argument but is instead doing what
the left does in general attack your
reputation and try and destroy your
source of revenue that is a confession
of weakness you know there is a fight
for Western civilization which I also
like to call civilization and it's not
gonna be pretty
I love the fact that they're getting
lazy that they're running to the
government that they're running to
advertisers rather than getting better
arguments and taking us on in the ring
if you're a boxer you really love it
when the other guy sits on his stuff
Cheetos into his face and doesn't train
because the everyone's gonna have to get
into the ring at some point I love the
fact that we're getting leaner and
meaner while they're getting fatter and
lazier yeah actually a regular guest on
the show Chael Sonnen he's an MMA
fighter and all these MMA fighters used
to try and act virtuously would say well
I hope my opponent is up I hope he's the
best
Anderson Silva ever fought and shale
slider up we go why would I say
why do I want to fight the best and I
want to fight a sickly ill-prepared
underserved under coached Anderson Silva
kick his ass and go home without a
scratch that's how I feel about you
about YouTube
I didn't you see the left because we had
Karen strong some people say well it's
not a political issue and you can tell
me what your take is on it now I
understand their people um gosh what's
his name I forgot his name
pat pat pat remark no no no pac-man
pac-man his name is his nickname
I don't know Karen Strom was talk I
guess he's a liberal and he was
demonetized now I do think that this has
affected some liberal channels that take
on controversial subjects I'm willing to
acknowledge that but if you look at
their active support YouTube's active
support of The Young Turks and Samantha
bee and Trevor Noah
I think it's pretty clear that they've
they've bet on some liberal horses and
the other liberal horses get screwed but
there's not a single conservative or
right leaning horse and a stable I mean
you can't find one so I do think it's a
combination of both but they don't want
right-wingers to have a seat at the
table do you think that spill found it
or have you seen that Oh non leftists on
YouTube I mean it's our domain it's our
hood yeah we own this particular
platform and you know they've managed to
you know transcend any kind of
objectivity with regards to Facebook and
Twitter and other platforms so yeah this
is our neck of the woods now I think
that what they've done in the attempt to
appear more fair is they've you know
they've obviously demonetized
controversial stuff as a whole but the
problem is of course as you know Steven
leftist stuff is generally mainstream
these days and so if you're going to
start hitting controversial stuff you're
going to disproportionately hit non
leftist and of course it does help that
it promotes the mainstream media who are
considered to be authentic news
practical news regular old gotta be
honest news and so the mainstream media
is monetized and is available in
searches and is promoted but they're
generally on the left as well I mean the
last holdout was Fox and it looks like
they're crumbling now as well so yeah if
you're gonna just say well mainstream
media is fine that automatically is it
to me at least a leftist bias to begin
with oh I think so especially with the
moving goalposts right with what's
considered offensive the truth is right
now if you believe that you are born
biologically a male or female that's
considered offensive that can be filed
as hate speech you're not going to find
leftists who say that which brings me
kind of to a point now I know you and I
would disagree on probably multitude of
issues
50/50 or we'd agree and disagree
probably I would say maybe a few years
ago we would not be talking as much we'd
probably seen as more so on opposite
sides of the fence do you think though
that just because of how intolerant and
narrow-minded the left has become that
has created a bigger tent for sort of
conservatives right-wingers I guess you
would say libertarian philosophers I
don't wanna misrepresent you but you
know you're not the I guess sort of a
conservative in the traditional sense
yet here we are and it doesn't seem like
the left can even do that well all I
want is for the conversation to continue
the conversation called civilization
well you bring reason you bring evidence
you bring your best rhetorical and
skills to to a conversation you debate
and it is in that furnace it is in those
sparks that the sword gets sharpened and
of course I'm talking about the
allegorical sword and all that but I
just want you've been flat to continue
so when you've got people on the left
you know when they've got them throwing
rocks when you've got them planning acid
attacks at right-wing gatherings or non
leftist gatherings when you've got them
setting fire to policemen in Paris well
that kind of shuts down the conversation
I you know I've chatted with liberals on
this show people on the left on the show
wherever there's a civilized
conversation man I'm there I'm in like
Flynn but when you have people who want
to pull fire alarms who want to stop
speakers from coming to campuses
publicly-funded campuses yeah well then
I think we have a common enemy there are
those of us who want to have the freedom
to disagree and converse and there are
those of us of those over there who want
to shut everything down and impose kind
of martial law in the realm of ideas and
I think we can all get together and say
you know that guy in the choir you know
who brings the air horn and a sheep and
keeps rotating its hips slowly to make
it sing that guy's making us all sound
bad that guy's got to go so we can get
back to some harmony and sing off so rap
off so whatever yeah well I appreciate
you it is a multi-ethnic audience here
so appreciate you injecting the rap the
hip-hop culture because that's important
for us to maintain our base we just do
he's had four black guys I'm tuning out
I believe so I try not to appear too old
and out of touch on these guys of shows
well if you're Canadian you appear old
enough touched no matter what when it
kind of that's like that's
one thing huge will Drake is from your
neck of the woods there in Canada Drake
and he's I'm like he is from a welt he's
a half Jew who played a paraplegic in
the Degrassi show whoo now he's a
butter-soft [ __ ] who now sounds like
he's from Memphis I'm like how does this
fakery through the rap industry as a
Canadian I can't get my ignorant poor
people to have access to Google yes
that's the problem here I only have Bing
um so okay sir we've got enough trek
yeah you know I'm glad to hear you say
that because well for example I know
you're you're would you say a theist
would would you I don't want to some
people don't like the term atheist
you're an atheist I'm a Christian
is that a fair well here's the thing
here's the thing philosophically I'm an
atheist
but over the last couple of years I've
had I daresay an evolution towards a
massive and deep appreciation of not
just my Christian heritage but the
West's Christian heritage and I've
actually found that I like Christians a
lot more than atheists okay you tend to
be a kind of high-strung kind of
aggressive often underemployed and
statistically this is true so my sort of
particular concern is that what I love
about Christianity is to focus on the
individual conscience and you can't
point guns at people and make them good
right the moment you're introduced force
in the Christian theology into
somebody's moral behavior boom out goes
the morality you know it's like
introducing force into dating suddenly
you're just a creep in a windowless van
yeah and all of a sudden it's rape I
know believe me we've had to deal with
this so so the fact that Christianity
stands for a small estate which allows
people to pursue moral choices and get
to heaven that way means that I'm far
more in alignment with Christian ideals
and Christian philosophy than I am with
atheists who seem to want to get rid of
God so that they can blow the state up
to like biblical proportions well you
know it's ranging that you said because
I I have seen that and I've seen you
talk about that and I think it's a it's
very thoughtful and the reason I brought
it up is because yeah I think a lot of
people I mean I've been on YouTube for a
long time and so most Christians on
YouTube I would say from probably about
2009 until 2015 we didn't really get a
seat at the table to represent our own
views it was angry atheists who kind of
dominated YouTube who would represent it
for us like they don't believe in
evolution we didn't get to say hold on :
that's not true you know we didn't get
200
evolution yeah I'm not a big Pope guy
either but I think you have a better
grasp I think I'm probably sort of the
the fundamental concept of Christian
like not Cajun I've talked about some
social justice warrior Christians who
take Christ's give unto Caesar what is
render unto Caesar what is Caesar's as
give it all the Caesar and do it by
force but it singeing that we can find
common ground there today because the
left is is again so intolerant
Christians and atheists kind of coming
together just just as free thinkers and
that just really interests me I feel
like that's been an acceleration in the
last year and a half two years where
atheists and Christians have found
common ground against the left blob well
this is the things that Christianity is
a conversation it's one of the few
religions that is primarily spread by
the wood and not by the sword I'd like
some others and so the fact that
Christianity is a conversation has far
more in common with philosophy than
somebody who's an atheist who wishes to
spread his ideas through the power of
the state atheism to the to the degree
that it aligns itself with state power
is a coercive religion just as communism
was a coercive religion communism is
traditional hatred for Christianity was
the hatred of a self directed conscience
based ethic that stood in the way of the
expansion of state power it was like
like how they have a math you would hate
a cop you know yes well the cop stands
to the expansion a stance against the
expansion of the Mafia and so I find
myself when it comes to my particular
dedication which is you know the
non-aggression principle personal
property rights self ownership and so on
that dovetails very nicely and and to be
honest you know I thought all of this
stuff was original but the more I looked
in sort of my own history of my own
heart Steve Moore I realized that it
came out of my Christian upbringing this
idea of the individual conscience that
you don't run to the state that you have
conversations with people that you
reason with people as best you can and
try and convince them to be good right
rather than say you got to help the poor
and if you don't give me half your
income you're going to jail yeah that is
not part of my upbringing and of course
I pillaged a lot of that and took pride
in it but the honest truth when I sort
of sat down and really thought about it
was if I hadn't been raised as a
Christian I don't really think I would
have ended up with that starting place
if that makes sense no it does and
that's very that's really interesting to
hear actually um because it's not
necessarily know you do have well
actually have you have you read it all
alik Ryrie professor he was on the
program and is it protestantism the
what's name of the book Protestantism
the Western he'll on the show that's
reality but he does talk specifically
more so about Protestantism and uh of
course the history of Martin Luther
where he wasn't just standing up so much
against the church if you look at
actually kind of a political
establishment of that day and I don't
even going back to you know if you go
into the Bible of Pharisees and
Sadducees and he talked about how
specifically Protestantism was founded
on this idea of being deeply skeptical
and questioning Authority and obviously
when that turns into accept the church
Authority that becomes a problem but the
way I was raised with Christian parents
they always encouraged me to you know I
wasn't raised Catholic it wasn't this
person's word is is divine or this
person is infallible although I
understand that relates only to
spiritual issues it was always hey
listen yeah question anyone any any
anything you hear in church question it
asked me questions and um I don't you
know I don't know that necessarily my
Islamic friends or where I was in
Montreal had that upbringing probably
not they were probably killing people
well this is but this is the challenge
right I mean so skepticism which was the
foundation of the scientific method and
so on a skepticism also was the
foundation of the Industrial Revolution
because sort of way back in the day
there was such a tight control under
Catholicism of the economy right like
believe it or not that's these wild
stories about if you were walking
through a market like in sort of
fourteen thirteenth century and so on if
someone sneezed they could be banned
from the marketplace because what
happens is if you sneeze then somebody
is obligated as a Christian or just a
decent person to stop and say bless you
and then you might fall into a
conversation where the guy can sell you
something
so sneezing was considered an unfair
competitive practice and you weren't
allowed to do it you weren't allowed to
find these so there was such a tight
control over the economy right and there
the Protestants of course came along
with this massive skepticism the
foundation of Protestantism was
something's really gone wrong with
religion and let's stop having the
priest yell at us in Latin and let's
actually start reading stuff for
ourselves and this is you know I did
this show years ago but this is a direct
parallel to what you and I and others
are doing on the Internet this is the
new Gutenberg this is the new printing
press right there was all of these texts
that were held
in private in secret in foreign
languages and you weren't allowed to
read them for yourselves and now then
with Luther translated the Bible to the
vernacular so that people could read it
and discuss for themselves and think for
themselves and reason for themselves
give people access to the primary text
let them think for themselves well let
people think for themselves is the
foundation of the modern world
stop being told what to do stop being
told what to think outside of government
schools the mainstream media academia
etc etc and this is the new Protestant
revolution I think what's going on on
the Internet where we can have these
conversations directly plug into the
minds of people with no intermediary no
censorship and this going back to the
monetization issue Steven this is what
the D monetization is supposed to do
it's supposed to get you to start self
censoring who do I really want to spend
three days rather the real problems in
this video if it turns out I got a 50/50
so this soft censorship is the real
problem and you just have to grit your
teeth and drive through that you know
we'll find a way to flourish and survive
because I think we have the truth of the
process on our side the truth of the
conclusion who cares like it's like
science philosophy thinking
conversations is a process as long as we
continue with the process I passionately
and with integrity and with honesty I
don't think there's anything that can
stop us because there's no putting this
genie back in the bottle yes I agree
it's you gotta rub it before it breaks
Gooden Berg analogy we don't even gotten
on the show we've gotten Hindenburg what
every time with this program it's just
referring to your guns with that t-shirt
yes I can see because if your audience
who this is these are this is a romper
it's not a tits I don't wear tank tops
that would be douchey Stefon that would
be embarrassed things definitely okay we
do have to get going here because I
could talk about this all day and one
thing I do want to touch on you said the
process is really what matters I think
that's an important an important facet
here
that a lot of people gloss over you know
atheists and Christians can respect and
adhere to the same process and come to
different conclusions so I think it's
actually pivotal that you said that that
the process of what matters and again
when you talk then you have a leftist
who come and go this is a process and
they toss it out you know with the
aborted baby in a wastebasket listen
you've been a big president Trump
obviously advocate fan the general
consensus is the last couple weeks have
been kind of tough what's been your view
on it I just I'm exhausted with it all
well Steve that's because you're
listening to the media and the first
thing you want to do have you ever had
it in your life I just had a call-in
show with this recently and a guy called
in and he said oh you know I'm droppings
with my girlfriend she she thinks that
we want to have babies she wants to have
babies and I never really wanted to have
babies blahdy blahdy blah and she's
bringing all this stuff up and it's
driving me crazy
so I'm like okay put her on and then she
says well you know for the first two
years he was saying oh here's what our
babies are gonna be called and here's
what you know I want two boys and a girl
and this then the other and so once you
get the other side it all kind of no
longer makes any sense what the first
person is saying you're getting the side
from the media particularly around this
Comey memo the Comey memo you know
something that someone wrote at some
point at some point in the past nobody's
actually seen it all that happened is
the New York Times yeah had someone who
claims to be having inside knowledge
read parts of this memo to them it's not
interference in a in an FBI
investigation it's not any kind of
illegal action it's just him saying hey
I best for my friend I hope that it
doesn't go too far you know this kind of
stuff it is not any kind of torturous
interference it is not anything illegal
and if it was Tomi's in deep crap
because Comey is supposed to report any
interference in FBI investigation right
and if he didn't that is actually
illegal and he could be brought up on
charges he could lose his license to
practice law
if Trump did something that was illegal
and Comey didn't tell him tell anyone
didn't and and now it's just floating up
what right after the guy got fired he
didn't even tell the guy who's the
Acting Director of the FBI and so Comey
himself has said nobody interfered in
investigations the acting FBI director
said nobody interfered in investigations
this is a media generated panic scandal
that's just designed to appeal to well I
think it's immediate generator Dems
don't like democracy when it doesn't go
their way and now they want to change
the outcome of the election so they're
manufacturing all of this stuff I don't
know I know I understand you don't think
it's true please no no I don't think
it's I don't think is entirely
manufactured and I certainly went to
that we're only getting one side of the
media my issue is more so Donald Trump
here's the issue here with Donald Trump
he's hanging his team out to dry by not
having a cohesive message together and
it makes them look stupid or it makes
them look incompetent when you know you
have Kellyanne Conway going on saying no
no sensitive information was discussed
now talk about
to fight information by the way he's
present he can declassify whatever he
wants so I want to make that clear but
then when he tweets out yes I did
discuss sensitive information they're
just they need to get into a huddle and
make sure they're on the same page
because they give more validity to
completely unsourced completely
unsubstantiated claims from the left by
just giving them I wouldn't even say an
inch they're giving them a foot and the
left's going to take ten miles and I
just wish you were a little more tactful
we were talking about this today you
know you're relatively I mean compared
to Donald Trump the sort of modicum of
fame or notoriety that we have right but
as someone who's a philosopher and seems
interested in psychology you've probably
encountered this is this is what I see
as an issue as far as behavioural
patterns you've probably encountered
people who already recognize you right
and they come up in their fans they
behave with you very different all I do
is sorry to interrupt but I basically
just grabbed them by the [ __ ] because
it's really really important to milk
that fame for what it's worth
yes yes exactly well I think I have it
on a bumper sticker somewhere so you but
you understand it like these people they
interact with you right we would agree
differently than people who've known you
for a long time well ever since Donald
Trump has been of age to the point where
you keep an understand money every
relationship he's ever had with someone
has effectively been that it's been a
money relationship where people are to
some degree enamored with him he's
famous he's wealthy and I sit I think
you see that sometimes and not having
people around him who might criticize
him who might provide him with some
valid criticism to correct because we
see him making some of these
miscommunication mistakes in a row and
for us that's kind of what we sat down
and realized this week almost all of his
relationships as an adult since he's
been old enough to have these adult
relationships have been with people
beholden to him to some degree and and I
do think that's a problem and I hope
they get some Outsiders in there just so
that they can get the story straight
because it does get tough to follow but
so he met he met with the Russians and
he talked about stuff that wasn't
classified and and that's perfectly fine
yeah I mean there's nothing but I'm sure
you just want to do it now the
interesting thing is that some of the
information that was leaked to the
mainstream media appears to be more
classified in other words right people
doing the leaking who may potentially
have broached some classified topics not
Donald Trump in his meeting with the
Russians so I read he said they said
there are so much sensitive information
immigration law to be enforced if taxes
can be lowered fantastic you know the
is of interest to a lot of people and
this idea of like well did he say
something untoward in some meeting but
the rush like this is nonsense it
doesn't matter people are saying that
yeah the one thing I do think matters
those is I'm not timeout classified and
we agree on that what I'm saying what
matters is as far as because the Vegas
odds have gone to a 60% chance of him
being impeached
now this isn't fake this is these are
the Vegas betting odds they get it right
they get it wrong sometimes and I think
the reason they're seeing that is it can
not that he talked about classified
information but the concern is that he
sent out people his subordinates with
marching orders that he then
contradicted you know an hour later and
that makes them look really bad and
that's not something that a good leader
does and that comes with experience but
my point is when they say no no
sensitive information was discussed no
information regarding terrorism but when
he says when they say you know listen we
had written a formal letter to fire comb
and he says who cared about letter I was
gonna fire him anyway and contradicts
the memos that they've been given my
issues just I I hope he gets that
leadership just a little tighter so the
left doesn't take the ball and run would
say there's look look smoke smoke yeah
look look smoke because I didn't seem
like there is all of these sources are
unnamed and you have to protect your
sources we understand that with
journalism right but when CNN in New
York Times when they're all unnamed
sources when they're all listen if they
want to take any kind of legal action at
some point the source is going to have
to be revealed
and no one wants to take the reputation
on it so I think it is most mostly
fakery I just think he gives them a
little too much leeway as far as a
leadership ability that's my criticism
well okay let me let me sort of give you
a counterpoint let me know what you
think so I you know if you had literally
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people combing over everything that you
said and did just trying to find
something that they could get a ship in
through that would be a pretty tough
life to have right I mean I mean that
would just be a very very tough
existence to sort of wend your way sure
through and so are there going to is the
left gonna find some contradiction from
here or there was one thing said and
then another term was used
why give any a bit oxygen that's my
question why give any of this media
hysteria oxygen it doesn't matter what
matters is what his agenda was his
support from the American people for
what he wants to do what matters is the
job growth what matters is the economy
growth what matters are the
scats the enforcement of immigration law
that's what matters my concern is that
you may to some degree by the Fanning
their flames by giving some of this
stuff oxygen what does it matter if well
one person says the word sensitive
sensitive doesn't mean classify it just
means delicate so right here's what was
said in that meeting it doesn't matter I
think we need to try and drag people's
attention away from this constant bat
screeching hysterical media and just
people get people back to the bigger
issues because I'm concerned that some
people as a whole are kind of feeding
into and you're Fanning the flames well
they've got a point about this they got
a point I don't think the left is much
of a point about anything I do think
this week they have some not the left I
do you think any I think some some some
detractors have some points and I try
and hear what their points are and say
okay you know well maybe it maybe have a
point there I don't think you know for
example we can talk about the what we
can talk about another time we have so
much so much to get into but I don't
think I'm fanning the flames are giving
it more oxygen and Donald Trump's
Twitter I think if we want to give it
less oxygen I think just having a small
meeting before going out there
half-cocked with a tweet that
contradicts his team that's what I'm
saying
I think we could fan the flames less if
they were just a little bit tighter
because the last thing you want to do is
some slip-up all of a sudden makes the
Young Turks write about anything by
accident god forbid it's not happening
yet I don't think it will but I just
don't want it to happen at some point in
the next four years that's my nightmare
stefan molyneux free domain radio.com
hey speaking of the monetization how can
people support you right now oh well of
course a freedomainradio.com slash
donate is the place to go I entirely
survive on listener donations my videos
are not monetized I sell a couple of
books but no merchandise and all that so
yeah people want to support of course
you know like subscribe share and so on
and of course I would recommend this for
your show as well to anybody who listens
to this from my side of the aisle but
yeah youtube.com slash freedomain radio
or freedomainradio.com and you know
listen for a while like subscribe share
the usual thing oh by the way one last
story so the other day I had this story
about a kid who was little 2 to 3 year
old who was going to bed going to bed
and he goes up the stairs and he says
please like subscribe and share because
his parents have been watching so much
youtube that he thought that meant
goodbye well I think the kid needs a
nanny
freedomain radio god I think YouTube is
his nanny
that's why we take that's what we take
so much responsibility on ourselves at
this program for the children
freedomainradio.com is definitely thank
you very much we will talk with you soon
there's music thanks Dave great pleasure
[Music]
many of you are still unaware of the
items available at louder with Crowder
shop calm not only do they make you look
and feel better but they serve a
multitude of purposes like our socialism
is for five shirts assisting in
identifying potential allies I think
it's pretty funny or our bad hombres
firearm t-shirt helping you know who to
avoid I might have take that shirt to
mean you support some kind of firearm
registry or this one hey look it's my
face I hate it though louder with
Crowder shop calm isn't for everyone but
can i buy the mug from the shop without
joining the mug club no the rest of you
check out the merchandise at Lauder with
Crider shop calm today it's library time
it's library time for those I don't know
that's reference to video game arcade
and top 10 the show on YTV in Canada
stefan molyneux knows because he's over
there
hey stefan molyneux is a member of the
Month Club you can be too and if you
don't want to we have a 7 day free trial
on YouTube next week as you saw Stefan
talking with us he's funded by donations
we don't do donations we do the mug club
where you also get access to the entire
CR TV lineup mark levin michelle malkin
a bunch of new names to come they've
just shot a bunch of pilots out there
and it also keeps everyone employed the
Jared Edward Francine Gerald to a degree
Erin Courtney Casey Brautigan Corey it
really is your support that keeps these
people in business and if your student
$69 annually so ninety-nine dollars
annually sixty-nine dollars annually if
you're a student veteran or military
entering the discount in that we can't
thank you enough for the support YouTube
has made this a necessity daily show you
can have it on the app you can watch it
on the go it's actually we're going a
new platform because of the people who
join us through club it's going to be a
whole lot better than YouTube's platform
and it's what allows us to keep fighting
back on YouTube and keep creating the
free content like Stefan was talking
about he he lives off of the donations
he keeps it going by the donations that
you sent and that's what keeps him on
YouTube funding back it it's what keeps
YouTube conservative territory the left
may not like it but we
own that plot of land pretty much not we
don't technically own it but you get it
digitally like a digital agricultural
revolution ladder with greater calm
slash mug Club thanks so much for your
support and please join if you haven't
if not you're probably a cheapskate but
we still appreciate you just less just
less
[Music]
all right you know I would say glad to
have our next guest but I will tell you
I think he suffers a little bit from
overexposure these days because I go to
my rheumatologist lo and behold who do I
see Matt Iseman on the cover of
arthritis today what's the conversation
like with your agent like hey you hurt
how could you tell me suffering from
overexposure in that outfit they're
brutal
well I mean Dean Cain didn't even wear
that back back in the 80s
no that's true I wish Dean came or
nothing this is my third time on the
cover of our threads Today magazine I
know I put my pants on one leg at a time
I'm still human and it's extremely
painful it's it's for me it's been great
having been involved with your education
for over a decade now it's been nice
getting to tell my story and becoming I
like to say is celebrity amongst the
[ __ ] community really one of the
breakout stars of it well that was the
last time you're undercover the next
byline is just an apology I apologize
for previous cover model Matt Iseman the
comments you know we all we all struggle
with with with joint pain and yeah and
you know for some of us it's a little
more severe but but that's the entire
reason that I'm on the cover that
magazine that's why I competed for
Arthritis Foundation on Celebrity
Apprentice I think it's important for
people to tell their stories because
yeah particularly for for four men and
four guys who I'm still relatively young
not compared to you guys but for people
who are out there who are suffering from
this disease it can be kind of isolating
yeah I think it's important for people
to know that there are others out there
who have arthritis rheumatoid arthritis
and are still leading full lives and
yeah Twitter a host of American Ninja
Warrior and they have celebrity Ninja
Warrior coming up soon when's that
happening it's on May 25th it's part of
Red Nose Day it's actually it's gonna be
us it's uh Bear Grylls running wild he's
gonna have Julia Roberts give me a lot
telethon and we'll be we'll be out there
in New York it's been nice I think NBC
has really started to show a lot of
attention and appreciation to NBC great
unlike those pieces of human crap at ABC
you were talking about this Tim Allen
you know I run into him quite a bit
every now and then in the summer I don't
know him at all I think he also is one
who refused to do our show Last Man
Standing was canceled mm-hm and you've
been following this I mean it was the
second highest rated comedy over there
at ABC and it won its timeslot regularly
actually because success sometimes a
show's success can work against it then
you get to the point where I think he's
heading into the season six or season
seven six years and the problem with
success salaries go up costs go up and
what I'd heard was that that the show
was actually becoming prohibitively
expensive because everyone deserved
higher salaries that was the story that
I heard and that I hope to believe you
know the one that I think ten appeals
actually happened was he expressed some
conservative beliefs right he expressed
some conservative beliefs and maybe
wasn't as artistic about it anytime you
invoke 1930 Germany yeah the show was
really right leading the show was
constantly throwing jabs at Barack Obama
and Hillary Clinton also Donald Trump
yeah I mean I will say this to people
like out there I find a more fair show
than here we make we legitimately make
one of I have I have five Roger Ailes
jokes here that I could not use today
that's how the stories last mat standing
made it as long as it did you know to me
and that's that's one of the things that
I that's why I like your show I think I
feel there's a balance there and that
you're open you you and Joe Rogan I
think are two of them
you're underrated as interviewers in
that I think you you invite people in
who have views that are all across the
spectrum and I think you genuine
genuinely listen to them and engage them
and that's for me that's what I like I
don't want to hear an echo chamber I'm
waiting here someone who hears different
points of views and who either pokes
holes in them or realizes their own
mistakes but in either way you hopefully
your knowledge base is growing and it
unfortunately as I look at it I just
don't see a lot of that going on and
particularly from house claustrophobic I
mean my thing is I just I really do feel
as though today the left isn't capable
of laughing at themselves I mean when
you look at how much flack we'll get for
Donald Trump jokes today Samantha bee
Seth Meyers from they are incapable of
making jokes about whether it's Hillary
Clinton whether it's Nancy Pelosi like
when something there is anything right
it's t-ball for them they choose to sit
it out I am amazed I'm like how can you
how can you even remotely consider
yourself a consistent comedian with this
it's okay to have a point of view and
you're seeing this with
last-man-standing like every other show
is super far left and this is a show
that makes fun of both sides has a more
middle American bent and it's gone I
don't buy the salary thing even if a
winning product you figure out how
what's your opinion I will tell you with
television we've learned there there are
innumerable variables and it's
impossible to know what's going on I
think it is unfortunate because I feel
the same way where you're starting to
hear very very much one side dominate in
terms of comedic ly and again yeah I
feel then it's not fun you know I much
rather prefer to hear people taking
shots and I and I feel like when you
look at the country Trump you know it
may not be 50% but a lot of people
supported the president and support
these points of view and I feel like
haven't consistently be one side you end
up eliminating one side is it bright on
one side or did you have a stroke
because one of your eyes is repeatedly
closing
this on drips I have a lazy eye the
crazy deserves monetize you said I'm in
front of them for his lazy listen it
come on okay if you're looking for
embarrassment alright okay make fun of
myself more I just I really for me I
think comedy nothing should be sacred my
comedy I'm pretty straight-laced but I
love listening to people like Doug
Stanhope or Jim Norton who talked about
the most off-limits subjects but yeah
but are funny about it and I feel like
there shouldn't be any taboos we should
be able to laugh at everything and the
best comics can say things completely
antithetical to your beliefs but it's so
funny and there's some there's some
logic to it some truth to it and I feel
like comedy has been getting I don't
like to see comedy thoughtful least yeah
again I feel like every point of view
every neither South Park is the best to
me where it's either we make fun of
everything we make fun of nothing break
because it's it's everything should be
you know when they did the episode with
Mohammed yeah and drawing Mohammed I
thought yeah Comedy Central came down on
them and that was a thing and there was
a realization for them yeah I hope you
know with last-man-standing it's sad to
see that and it is sad to see them I
mean you expect it from networks and
unfortunately that's actually seeping
into the stand-up comedy world we've
talked about that with Jim Norton and
we've talked about with Nick DiPaolo and
that's what worries me you expect it
from ABC you know hey she's get up and
fly right
but hopefully like we talked about
stefan molyneux it's the self-censorship
i would hate to see comedy change
because people just don't want to take
the risk because they're afraid of those
repercussions we do have to get going
American Ninja Warrior at Matt Iseman he
won Celebrity Apprentice and goes to so
full copy of arthritis today
it will not be flagged I tell you that
will be wrapping this up after this
there's music thanks guys for the Diary
of Sean Spicer entry 934 dear diary
feels good to write over here again
tumultuous weeks like this it's time
where I find solace and all of the
familiarities of everyday life like you
a glass of red wine and my bed nestling
into my pillow I'm busy stay doing the
world diaries of Sean Spicer
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of current from the studio taking
you every which way
weirdo why this timing in the last I
meant with that kind of thing
the romper acts like a sail it catches
its very you don't wanna be wearing a
romper when you're caught in a Riptide
no well thanks to Matt Iseman what a
nice guy feel like such an ass I feel
like such I was sure cuz he's never done
that before I had no idea lazy eye I had
no idea I just I was sure it was a layup
like you know oh did you did you have a
stroke no it's a sunlight ha ha ha
you're not a you play one on TV and it
just sounds like oh he has a
neurological they're having there have
been few more embarrassing moments on
the show tweet us your stories I'm sure
as your people out there have story some
of the stories of assuming and making
jokes in that doesn't go so well
pregnant or something like that yeah
yeah a [ __ ] I've had that to me
people thought it was returning they
I've told you this or they thought I was
they perhaps thought I was autistic I'm
still not convinced yeah it's just just
turned out it was really boring school
was really boring I didn't like it oh no
he's not this kids never do story he
just doesn't like school otherwise known
as a boy yes otherwise known as a boy so
what we're gonna do and I just want to
drug him conics that's what we do now
man stefan molyneux we'll have to have
him back that was so nice and honestly
to support the the mud club so do get a
free domain radio and listen even though
I disagree with Stefan on a lot of stuff
I want to see people supporting I want
to see more voices out there like I said
it's amazing how wide this tennis think
about this this week's show
this week's yeah this week's show the
show's but this week's show collectively
but Stefan Molyneux Matt Iseman
who else what we had this week
gosh I'm sure remember you know it's
green once we get the one she like I'm
just on Lauren Southern asked by the way
so next week we do have Gavin I think we
have Poe go back we have Tommy Lauren in
studio
I think Sheriff Clark so and again tell
all your friends by the way those four
members of Mudd Club we appreciate it so
much but tell all your friends next week
every single episode is for free on
YouTube so you can see what a daily show
is like you know we want you to go to
bed with a smile on your face thinking
I'm not gay Jared we're gonna by the way
we'll have a Farrah Fawcett poster
available in a lot of credit shop com of
not get yours you can just put them on
the ceiling deal with it what you will
once you purchase it you know a big
reason for that too is a lot of people
are saying well you know I wish I just
don't know if I want to pay that you
know it ends up being five something
dollars a month especially it's always
challenging when we take an unpopular
viewpoint people get offended you know
with the Trump thing I can already see
some tweets coming some people are mad
some people like the fact that we
approached it in a balanced way I want
to see the guy do well I want to see the
country do that I think most people
understand this in this show we want to
see the country do well yeah now that
takes on a different angle depending and
who's in charge in the country with
because with Barack Obama for his ideas
to make it for his legislation to be
pushed forward the country overall would
have to do poorly in the long run sure
that's what I believe as far as
socialism but no matter who's at the
tiller of the ship I want to see the
country do well and the way the country
does well is if we follow the same
principles that made us a great country
of free enterprise rugged individualism
personal responsibility of course morals
and ethics which a lot of people don't
like to get into but as Stefan Molyneux
has talked about that's a huge
foundational principle of Western
society sure Harper wishbone by the way
taught us about that yesterday that'll
be up on YouTube for those who missed it
the separation of church and state and
often misconstrued it was not it's not
in the Constitution well you'll see the
video hopper wishbone aren't you good
actor hey he doesn't like me right now
don't bother me I'm busy but I will say
this I cannot you see some tweets people
who are mad we were telling this with
Matt Iseman genuinely when I watched
Samantha bee and I watched Trevor Noah
and I watched Seth Meyers and by the way
I think Seth Meyers can be funny I think
Stephen Colbert can be funny I do not
think Samantha bee has ever been funnier
Trevor Noah no but I do not ever see
them go after
the left surely not to the same degree
where we go after conservatives or the
right or Donald Trump it never happens
and it gets me so I'm like if you were
you cannot tell me as a comedian that
there is nothing to go after there and I
don't think there's another show out
there more fair
I really don't the one thing that that I
will take pride in with this show we
don't go out there and boast divide our
ratings it were the best we don't we
don't do any of that we don't really
some numbers but I do tweet made us
credit tweet at na kijiye
is there a show out there that you think
is more fair in its disposition and its
approach to Donald Trump for throne who
admits that we're conservative but from
the writers that were very
straightforward about our point of view
but I really do think that we go to
pretty great lengths to try and be at
least even-handed with our jokes on this
show we have a legitimate commitment to
actual comedy yeah also a legitimate
claim to UM
Jerald using the chainsaw outside no
we're installing a new generator in the
studio and so now you can hear him what
do you say something but Gerald comedy
what do you say is nothing but joy and
comedy those dude I have no idea
generally mix oh this show Jim McLean
the comedy legitimate I can just the
word I'm looking for
we we do things for comedy say because
we love comedy yeah we don't write
things off is also off-limits like
Samantha B clearly does right by the way
the Times Square incident I you know we
don't know a whole lot at this time so
we just haven't tried to talk about
obviously thoughts and prayers out to
those who were were hurt Roger Ailes we
wrote a ton of Roger Ailes jokes which
did not make air and again it's not
because I hate Roger Ailes but I know
that people will be really upset so
we'll probably make him next week and I
know dis I could I don't dislike Roger
Ailes I don't I don't hate any of the if
we joke what doesn't mean I hate them
no or if we criticize him doesn't I
don't hate Barack Obama I don't I don't
hate Donald Trump if I think he could
use some advice in in leadership ability
I don't hate Trevor Noah
Samantha he's getting there I don't hate
her but certainly not to make a joke
about them yeah I mean you know what
she's family
yeah you know that's a lot to cope with
I think it's the best you can do in the
media light the media light is go is
it's going to be what yeah well I
watched on CNN that little fat gay bald
guy what does a nymphet Kate ball get
seen and you know who I'm talking about
and right away they were just the first
thing they talked about with roger ailes
with a sexual harassment issue yeah but
their news this wasn't a joke there's
they consistent me all the accusations
of sexual harassment something come on
you you you tasteless bastard you're the
competing news network do you know how
this looks
if nothing else I am so glad that people
have seen because we talked about this
for years if you go back to our closing
segment about two years ago I would tell
people you know I don't don't don't so
much watch just MSNBC because you know
they have a bias but what bothers me is
CNN is the bias by omission is the lying
and what they choose not to cover and
and that's the problem with seeing and
you see it now now everyone basically
CNN and MSNBC are interchangeable
they understand how biased they are and
we don't want to do that with this show
where we choose not to make jokes about
a topic just because oh that could
offend some people on the right of the
left I think that's about as good as you
can do I think it's as good as you can
do in your personal life and as good as
we can do with the show I will never lie
to you but what's Roger Ailes up to now
stop it stop is he busy no stop
yes stop stop with the you know they're
right in the show method I if I glance
down I'm gonna have to read them um I
think it's as good as you can do III
don't think you know CNN went out or
Walter Cronkite and Dan Rather so I
tried to act like my god journalists and
now we know that they're not well
there's never gonna be a discovery where
you go did you know that Stephen is a
bias as a conservative yeah we never lie
about that and I think you try and be
honest
you try acknowledge your own biases and
challenge them that's as good as you can
do it's certainly a lot better than
lying to yourself and lying to your
audience as CNN in the New York Times
have done for a long time it's certainly
better than lying to yourself and the
people who pay you to keep them informed
when you deliberately keep them the dark
if it doesn't set your narrative I have
much more respect for even a Rachel
Maddow or even a Samantha bee
no not Samantha because she tries to
claim that she's just we're just going
after comedy when she's not she's a
liberal Canadian socialist in the United
States I think we should hopefully ice
gets a hold of her um but I have much
more respect for even a Keith Olbermann
where you know where he's coming from I
have much more respect for somebody who
can't look at themselves in the mirror
and say gosh I'm not gonna lie yeah you
know what you're a Lib you know what
you're a conservative you know what you
haven't to do we are conservative
absolutely a more right-wing libertarian
conservative I'm not the biggest Trump
in you know in the primaries but I want
to see the guy do well I want to see the
country do well certainly after the lad
at last eight years of Barack Obama I
want to see our course be set straight
that's where I'm coming from also I'm
gonna tell Wiener jokes because I find
them funny I think you need to do that
with your anyone out there if you think
that's the wrong approach if you think
people human beings are capable of being
objective truly objective without any
biases tweet me at s Crowder I don't
necessarily know that's possible and I
don't know it but necessarily know that
it's a virtue to try and act as though
it is because you're just not I don't
think it's an honest approach and I
think that what we do with this show is
also only trying to poach our life
except when it comes to rompers in that
case it's just an embarrassment all
around and everyone should feel great
shame as you should if you wear them in
your daily life we'll see you next week
tell your friends every single show on
YouTube free full shows
[Music]